Американець Крістофер - аварійник Служби швидког о реагування у Нью-Йорку.
Чоловік працював під час великих рятувальних операцій у США, зокрема, під час урагану "Катрина"
і теракту 11 вересня. Тепер Крістофер приїхав допомогти українцям, оскільки його досвід відповідає
необхідним під час війни навикам. Чоловік співпрацює
з українською громадською організацією.  До його завдань належить насамперед евакуація людей
з інвалідністю чи старших людей із гарячих точок. А також транспортування поранених солдатів у шпиталі
на безпечній території.Крістофер каже, що роботу ускладнює те,
що багато українців попри обстріли не хочуть залишати свої домівки.
Ми нещодавно евакуювали 2 старших жінок. Їхні сусіди також мали поїхати з нами,
я був впевнений у цьому. Але їх не обстрілювали вже кілька днів, тому вони сказали:
"Та ні, ми залишимося". Вчора одна з тих евакуйованих жінок, розповіла, що її двір розбомбили.
І вона боїться, що всі її сусіди загинули.
Тепер я відчуваю, що я підвів їх, що я старався недостатньо.
Вчора цілий день я думав, що мав би бути більш наполегливим і таки вивезти їх звідти…
Часто, каже волонтер, жінки з дітьми відмовляються від евакуації, бо не хочуть залишати чоловіків.
Крістофер вважає, що це неправильно.
Це боротьба чоловіків проти чоловіків. Я не хочу бути шовіністом.
Це не боротьба жінок з дітьми проти чоловіків. Для росіян справді байдуже -
вони знищують дитячі лікарні, розстрілюють жінок з дітьми на вулицях. Їм все одно, хто ти.
Окрім евакуаційної роботи, Крістофер також організовує збір пожертв для українців у США.
Завдяки прямому контакту з українськими активістами американець одразу закуповує на ці кошти те,
чого бракує найбільше.
Я також координую купівлю військових засобів захисту, які допоможуть солдатам.
Оскільки їм потрібна броня, кращі бронежилети, тепловізори, шоломи.
У мене є зв'язки в армії, тому ми намагаємося дістати необхідне і передати правильним людям.
Крістофер вміє також надавати першу медичну допомогу, хоч він і не спеціалізований лікар.
Тим часом, за даними міністерства охорони здоров'я, до України вже зголосилися приїхати
2000 іноземних лікарів. Деякі з них уже надають допомогу пораненим.
Одна з таких іноземок - ізраїльтянка Галія. Її бабусі і дідусі були польськими євреями, які пережили Голокост.
Для жінки це перша гуманітарна місія. Але вона не мала вагань, чи їхати до України під час війни.
Я нікого тут зараз не маю, але для мене як для лікарки, для педіатра...
Коли я почула, що людям необхідна була допомога тут, в Україні, я знала,
що це - моя місія, що тому я і стала лікаркою.
Галія приїхала рАзом з ізраїльською місією. Ізраїльтяни розгорнули польовий госпіталь у Львівській області,
неподалік від польського кордону. Тут працює загалом 80 медпрацівників.
Галія, окрім того, що лікує пацієнтів, займається також тим,
що презентує українцям інноваційні медичні технології.
Якщо ми поєднаємо ці частини, то це стане стетоскопом. Ми можемо покласти це на пацієнта,
а лікар у Ізраїлі зможе послухати, як працюють легені і серце людини.
Це один приклад технології, яку ми використовуємо, щоб ми могли надавати
краще лікування українським пацієнтам.
Завдяки цьому українці мають можливість дистанційно проконсультуватися
з провідними ізраїльськими медиками. Усі послуги надаються безкоштовно.
Ось ця жінка, наприклад, у неї анемія. Її ніхто не діагностував, вона не знала, що з нею.
Тепер вона може проконсультуватися зі старшим гематологом в Ізраїлі, який спеціалізується на цій проблемі.
Жінці сказали здати необхідні аналізи, і можливо, нам вдасться забезпечити її необхідним лікуванням.
Місію розгорнули за ініціативою ізраїльського уряду. За словами представників посольства,
набрати у відрядження до України охочих медиків не було проблемою. Навпаки, черга тих, хто хотів поїхати,
була такою великою, що довелося навіть відмовити кільком спеціалістам.
Лікарка-педіатр Карен спершу мала сумніви, чи їхати до країни, яка перебуває в активній фазі війни.
Однак вирішила, що не може залишатися осторонь.
Ми були трішки налякані. Але в моїй країні ми досить таки звикли до таких ситуацій,
ризикованих чи воєнних дій. І, як на мене, це одне з найважливіших місць зараз, щоб приїхати і допомагати.
Тому що легше бути лікарями у своїй лікарні з усім обладнанням, де є все необхідне.
Але значно важливіше і більша кількість викликів для дітей саметут.
Окрім дітей біженців, які тимчасово оселилися на Львівщині, лікарка також надає лікування
місцевим дітям з хронічними хворобами. Польовий госпіталь має амбулаторію, тож пацієнти
можуть приходити,  стільки разів, скільки необхідно, аби отримати необхідні діагностику й лікування.
На думку Карен, важливо не тільки один раз поспілкуватися з хворим, а й мати можливість
продовжити лікування, навіть дистанційно з Ізраїлю.
Ця місія багато чого мені дала - насамперед зв'язок з постраждалими.
Чути історії цих дітей, їхніх родин… Також важливо, що ми можемо продовжити лікування у майбутньому.
Це для мене як лікаря важливо, і я сподіваюся, для них також.
Ще один польовий госпіталь, який розгорнули в Україні, ініціювала міжнародна гуманітарна організація самаритян.
До цієї місії долучилися медики зі США, Великобританії, Австралії та інших країн.
Госпіталі працюють на Буковині, у Львівській області, ще один планується розгорнути на Київщині.
Американець Кріс працює лікарем швидкої допомоги в Індіанаполісі.
Чоловік мав відпустку і вирішив приїхати до України.
Він розповідає про велику кількість біженців, які прибули з гарячих точок.
Ми бачили травми в людей, які приїхали з гарячих точок, наприклад, з Маріуполя, Києва.
Вони мали поранення після стрілянини чи від уламків, і вони днями нічого з цим не робили.
Я бачив одну жінку, у якої уламок потрапив у стегно 3 тижні тому.
Вона аж 3 тижні добиралася з Маріуполя сюди, у неї було жахливе зараження в нозі.
Однак ми взяли її до себе, прооперували, дали антибіотики, і тепер у неї все чудово.
Госпіталь, в якому працює Кріс, щоденно приймає до 40 пацієнтів.
Чоловік каже, що роботи багато, тож він навіть ще не мав часу побачити місто,
в якому працює. Водночас він приємно вражений людьми, яких щоденно зустрічає.
Я був дуже вражений людьми. Тим, як вони борються за свою країну, життя, родину.
Це вражає. Однак також моє серце болить, коли я чую історії біженців. Наприклад, я спілкувався
з кількома людьми, які були в драмтеатрі Маріуполя, коли туди влучила ракета.
Їхні історії розривають моє серце. Тобто це сумно, але разом з тим мені приємно бачити рішучість українців.
Вони дуже милі люди з добрим серцем, яке їм болить, і я це відчуваю.
Волонтер Крістофер Лайонс щоденно виїжджає із Західної України у гарячі точки.
В Україні чоловік уперше і теж вражений мужністю українців.
Українці - унікальні люди. Я справді сподіваюся, що вони виграють цю війну.
Мені здається, світу потрібно більше людей таких, як українці. Вони дуже скромні і добрі.
Я незнайомець у цій країні, але я навіть не знаю, чи можу перерахувати, скільки разів
люди запрошували мене у свій дім. "Повечеряймо разом", "залишайся у нас ночувати"…
Я настільки не звик до такої поведінки в Нью-Йорку, ми так не робимо…
Якщо ми втратимо це, я думаю, ми втратимо щось у нашій людяності.
На думку Крістофера, українцям важлива не лише його робота,
але й сама присутність іноземців у їхній країні в ці нелегкі часи.
Це моя найбільша перевага тут - не просто допомагати людям, евакуювати їх.
Просто коли українці бачать, що я зі США, з Нью-Йорку, про який усі знають, і я приїхав сюди допомогти,
мене обіймали, мені тиснули руку, я не можу показувати, але мені навіть давали військові шеврони.
Люди дуже раді бачити тут когось, хто приїхав допомагати, як брат.
Крістофер мріє про те, щоб одного дня поїхати до Маріуполя, щоб допомагати відновлювати місто,
щойно його звільнять від російських загарбників.